la loi sur les normes du travail comme
un second j'ai commencé mon bac en droit
en 2008 puis n'est pas encore terminée
j'aime tellement ça que je les tire et
pendant longtemps occupé son esprit avec
des études même à temps très partiel
ça permet à alex hervé de garder une
forme d' équilibre parce qu'un athlète
de haut-niveau sollicite beaucoup son
physique
ce camp qui doit être parfaitement
fonctionnel à la saison 2014 alex a été
incommodé par une blessure à l'artère
iliaque blessure qui l'empêché de
fournir un effort maximal dans les
montées j'aimerais c'est sa mère qui est
un des médecins de l'équipe nationale
est retrouvé le problème c'est une
condition qui est très dur à à dépister
à diagnostiquer donc ma mère avait un
peu d'expérience avec d'autres athlètes
de la cave et vécues un problème comme
ça puis beaucoup dans la littérature
donc ça y est venu à l'idée
quand j'ai commencé à parler de mes
symptômes sont encore une fois ça a
permis de réagir rapidement donc c'est
grâce aux diagnostics rapides faire
suite à une opération au printemps 2015
la circulation sanguine d'alex est
redevenu normal ce qui lui permet de
rivaliser avec les meilleurs sa saison
2017 a été particulièrement intéressante
avec six podiums en coupe du monde et un
titre de champion du monde aux 50 km
chez très fier de voir comme un peu se
débrouiller puis à monter au travers de
saut il pourrait devenir vraiment la
tête enflée
moi ce que j'apprécie beaucoup c'est
qu'elle est c'est assez généreux il est
quatrième victoire on peut le voir j'ai
pu vivre avec eux en coupe du monde aux
championnats du monde alors quand lui
gang c'est toute l'équipe qui gagne les
gens pour aider alex sont encore plus
nombreux depuis les contre performances
de l'équipe canadienne aux jeux de
sotchi en 2014
alex peut maintenant compter sur des
facteurs très expérimenté mais aussi sur
un ski
les structures un excellent skieur qui a
les mêmes dimensions kalex et qui se
lève avant l'aurore pour s'assurer que
son champion puisse bénéficier du
meilleur matériel
j'ai une cinquantaine de paires de skis
qui sont alloués seulement moi donc lui
il fait il parle il élimine des départs
de ski au fur et à mesure du temps de m
moi quand j'arrive sur le site nord une
heure et demie avant le départ beloeil a
amené peut-être ça à trois quatre cinq
paires de skis donc à passer de 50 à 4 5
qui l'ont nommé cei ensemble on fait des
thèses liste comparative qui on ramène
ce hack une femme vous aurez compris que
faire de la compétition à ce niveau
c'est assez complexe
ils ont fait ce que fait l'équipe
canadienne ses traits plus si on compare
avec les grandes puissances du circuit
du mans le budget les norvégiens de
fartage et plus gros que le budget
opérationnel de ski de fond canada en
entier
ce qui rend les performances d'alex
encore plus exceptionnelle à pyongyang
alex en sera à ses troisièmes et
derniers jeux olympiques
il aimerait bien enfin monté sur le
podium pierre enlever son père qui a été
le premier canadien à remporter une
coupe du monde de ski de fond c'est très
bien que ce sera difficile mais il sait
aussi qu alex carbure aux défis les
certains athlètes que plus l'enjeu est
élevé
au lieu que la pression les écrase la
pression la semaine l'impression qu'alex
fait plus partie de ce groupe là
d'athlètes qu'une grande pression cela
aide à mieux faire encore et fiston alex
rêve de devenir le premier homme
canadienne à remporter une médaille
olympique marie josée turcotte radio
canada montréal
[Musique]